it's just not listed good evening ladies
and gentlemen and welcome you all to the
first
health school meeting of the municipal
year Wednesday 26th of July
um
so we can kick off then with just the
names of the new the new people well I
suppose there's new people amongst us so
if we could Puffs start at the very top
there and work down
next year Gareth James Deputy Place lead
for Health and Care integration
good evening uh Thomas Maloney our Tom
uh program director across health and
care for the council and nhsdm Trafford
hi I'm Karen Ahmed I'm director of all
age commissioning for Trafford Council
hi I'm councilor James Slater and I'm
the executive member for Health and Care
thank you
hi I'm councilor Shona Gilbert and I'm a
counselor for astronaut mersey Ward
Prime councilor Simon lapori for simply
Central
thank you
Oxford um
Hill Barnes and timpley Southward
councilor Denise West of broad Heath
Ward and chair our children's scrutiny
committee
good evening I'm councilor Sophie Taylor
counselor of Phil Crawford
laughs I'm counselor Tony O'Brien and I
represent astronomers award
[Music]
the Judith Lloyd Longford Ward
good evening Nathan Atkinson I'm the
corporate director for adults and
well-being the council
the director of adults
thank you good evening everybody and
Stephanie for a yearling governance
thank you so we'll start off the
the agenda item one nomination of the
chair
can we please uh confirm the appointment
to chairs Vice chair for the municipal
year cheers myself Council Dunbar and
Council
so if you tailored as the deputy chair
is that agreed
thank you
uh item two attendancies uh career
apologies
uh yes chair we've received apologies
from councilor
um chakrabrati
um Hartley Acton Leicester and Maitland
okay
and we have
participating
as officer has given apologies as well
thank you uh in item three Declaration
of interests
um
has anybody submitted them or is anybody
connected with the NHS or you know
perhaps uh any links
hi
um I'm a member of the RCN I've worked
within mft down to the moment but I'm
still on agency bank and I head up
training development for a private home
care company currently
Western all right yes I work in the NHS
not in Trafford I work in my Society
yeah
I work in the NHS um have an admin role
based at Wyndham Hospital which is part
of mft thank you
all the collisions complete
uh item four the minutes of the last
meeting for those that were here for
that meeting
is there any comments any anything to
bring up on there
if there isn't uh would you
regard that as a correct record
yes Chad thank you yeah second anybody
here
can we accept that
I'm sure that I was present chair you
were present yeah okay
thank you
so we'll accept those uh minutes
as read
thank you
item five the aid and adaptation service
update for Trafford and we're going to
receive a report
can we have that report please Nathan
certainly current chair
um so this is a report on the One-Stop
Resource Center
um it's a follow-up report from
um a deep dive review conducted in
November uh 2022.
um I think it's important to note that
this is a joint service
um with the Trafford local Care
Organization
um which is
um run by mft I think in terms of the
arrangements
for the service they are under what is
called the section 75 agreement under
the NHS act uh 2006. what this means is
it enables us to potentially pull
budgets though not in this instance
um but most importantly delegate
functions so the local Authority can
delegate functions to Health Partners
and Health Partners can delegate
functions
um to ourselves so the The Joint nature
of the service is quite critical the
service is run by Richard spearing who
unfortunately has given his apologies
today uh so myself and Karim Ahmed are
going to take take you through the
report on the aligned presentation
um but that will be very much from a
council perspective
um I think it's fair to say the service
has been significantly impacted like a
number of services
um by by the pandemic and the the Legacy
um is reflected in the report in terms
of some of the waiting lists and also
um issues around responsiveness and so
the report looks at how this can be
rectified
and the first draft of actions are
detailed in the report and will be
covered in in the presentation
um they are very much focused on
performance we recognize the services
not where we want it to be and but it is
on a journey and we we know there will
be further activity as the year
progresses and hence the the
recommendation in the reports come back
in September with a further update when
when some of the activity has been
conducted and where there may be further
activity
um to to come so I will hand over now to
Karen who's going to cover
um the presentation
apologies I've not been here before so
does the presentation go on the screen
or do you have a paper copy and I just
take you through the
paper copy okay thank you
all good right so
okay
um I haven't brought any copies with me
if you've got copies other copies in
there ah lovely thank you they're in the
pack
so um I Know Rich has been mentioned and
he does send his apologies he also said
he's really looking forward to giving
you an update on progress thank you in
September so he's looking forward to
come back then so we had a chat this
morning I went through the presentation
so that I try and reflect some of the
key points that Richard wanted to pull
out Nathan's given you the background
um to the um kind of the way that the
organization is managed so we have a
section 75 agreement in Trafford between
Trafford Council and mft and this
service forms part of that section 75.
as you might imagine the One-Stop
Resource Center provides a focal point
for referrals coming in for people with
a variety of need but all linked to
people who've got a permanent
substantial disability or people who
care for somebody who's got a disability
and the purpose of the services to
support that person to help them remain
as independent as possible and also to
gain as much Independence as possible if
they've lost see through example for
hospital admission
so we get a lot of referrals into the
One-Stop resource center from the
hospitals from GPS from other
professional social Care Professionals
and also members of the public can
self-refer that's unusual often
referrals have to go through a
professional so they do a preliminary
assessment rather than waiting to
actually be seen by an OT it is
something we're looking at reviewing in
the future to make sure that we are
getting the appropriate referrals
through so for example some of the
referrals we get in the One-Stop shop
um the One-Stop Resource Center are for
people who perhaps want a walking stick
which is an awful it takes a lot of time
really so they're waiting for a note to
go out and assess them then it's a you
know kind of quite a comprehensive
assessment where if somebody was seeing
quite sooner by a professional and maybe
referred to a different organization who
could help them choose a walking stick
and they could purchase themselves it
would be better for them and better for
the service so we're having a look at
things like that so
um the
OT assessment team has the equipment
advice and adaptation design also known
as eel as part of its kind of front end
and that's the the front door that most
of the people access the service for
um
so
I think the next page is the process
overview so I'm not gonna talk in too
much detail about that because it is
it's quite complicated also
self-explanatory so it tells us where
the referrals are coming in
um they come into the um eel team and
then they might be referred to the
adaptations team for
um an adaptation after the OT assessment
is being carried out or they might be
um referred to the ones the sort of the
stores for equipment so if somebody's
assessed by an OT and they require a
piece of equipment there's admin support
to book that equipment and order the
equipment and then they manage the
delivery within that service and as you
see when we go on to the next page
um there's been quite a backlog and a
delay in terms of actually being able to
deliver the equipment so in a sense
we've got two key points of of delay
within the service there is a delay for
OTs Investments and there's also a delay
for the receipt of equipment unusually
there's not enough delay for adaptations
because the adaptations team have
capacity to take on on more work at this
current point in time that's not usually
the case usually there's often a wait
for the adaptations team so we've had
them
a number of issues
um during the past 18 months that have
contributed to a backlog for equipment
orders
um we're reviewing the driver service at
the moment with the view to looking at
what improvements we can make because
the lack of drivers has impacted on our
ability to deliver equipment to people's
homes but when we've done an analysis
the key delays seem to be that we can't
actually get into that person's home so
we book deliveries we go there and we
attempt delivery and that's not
successful so then we bring the piece of
equipment back and then we attempt to
gain another day so you have noticed
throughout the report reference to Elms
Elms is a management system
and that should help us manage not just
where the referrals have gone to in
terms of the order for pieces of
equipment but also where that is within
the system it also helps us deliver the
pieces of equipment because it enables
us to book a delivery once we're there
where the piece of equipment's on its
way and Richard described it as kind of
like booking a delivery of a fridge
freezer or something a washing machine
something like that so it should be a
lot smoother we should be able to get
pieces of equipment to people in a more
timely manner and it's a more effective
and efficient use of the delivery
service as well
um so that's the the kind of the
rationale behind the
um the difficulties that we've been
experiencing really with the delivery
service and the delivery of equipment
the OT assessment team there are delays
there and there's a slightly different
rationale behind that so during covid
um all of the there was a national
directive for all of the occupational
therapy
therapists to be pulled back within the
hospital so they were pulled back
unfortunately at that time the eel line
was left open so a number of referrals
were still coming in so when the OTS
returned back to their Community roles
there was already a massive waiting list
there for people who needed pieces of
equipment we assessed the the waiting
list
um around April May last year and looked
at the capacity within the team and it
was clear from that assessment at that
point that we wouldn't be able the team
themselves would be able to match the
demands and the waiting list so our
analysis so far has shown us that we
think there's the demand that's coming
through on a regular basis should be
able to be met by the adaptation sorry
the occupational therapy team in terms
of assessment capacity when it's full
and there's there have been issues in
terms of recruiting and at the moment
there's one post out to advert but
generally speaking they should be able
to manage the demand but we recognized
that there were people waiting who had
been waited for a long period of time
that we had to look at doing something
differently with
so we went out to Tender for a partner
to help us deliver the occupational
therapy assessment so we've contracted
with an organization called the OT
practice so the initials are totp very
easy to remember because it's like top
of the box and that's how we all
remember it
um they've been really good in terms of
stepping up and taking on board those
assessments so they've conducted 400
assessments to date and we've handed
over a number of other assessments to
them to start working their way through
um what we've we always scrutinize those
this before they go to the OT practice
to ensure that that person is still
requires that piece of equipment that
their situation hasn't deteriorated and
we don't need to provide a different
kind of assessment to minimize the risk
to traffic residents we've not given any
pediatric cases over to the OT practice
we wanted to keep the children's cases
close to um close to us and to manage
those we've also not given them any
complex cases so those cases where you
require adaptations and that's because
they take a lot longer if you're talking
about things like an extension
um and therefore you need closer working
with the OT and with the adaptations
team because issues might arise during
actually that the design and the
delivery of that adaptation they the
first time the first tranche they had
which were the first 400 so in total
we've commissioned 800 Assessments in
two trenches of 400 they've nearly
completed the first tranche of 400 and
they're just starting the second tranche
of 400. the first tranche was very
simple assessments because we wanted to
check the quality of those assessments
and make sure they're okay the second
trans has been slightly more complex so
it involves people for example who need
level access showers
and and those kind of adaptations so
that we're getting through those quite
quickly in terms of the other
assessments that OTS carry out we've got
a fast track now from the OT service
into the adaptations team so we Fast
Track anything like
um
uh anything like for services for people
with motor neurone disease so those
neurological disorders because those
people deteriorate quite quickly if
they're not supported very early on in
their journey and those pieces of
equipment that we can provide quite
quickly so things like
um level access showers you know the
adapted bathrooms stair lifts hoists
those kinds of things we we can move
very quickly on those in ramps and we
get those those fast tracked
um we I wouldn't say we're on the ball
but I actually was asked to approve one
so they moved them straight through if
they're under five thousand if they're
over five thousand they come to me one
was in my inbox for 13 hours and I had a
reminder from the person who'd sent it
to me that that I hadn't responded and
approved or not approved that case so
they really are on that border team and
they're pushing everything through as
fast as possible so people do get those
adaptations the other area where we Fast
Track our Hospital discharges and people
on the end of on an end-of-life care
pathway so what we do is we actually
keep slots as particularly for delivery
equipment during the day so that we can
deliver pieces of equipment to people
the same day
um in most cases for people either who
are coming out of hospital or an
end-of-life pathway
um
so we
um we've we think so the way the OT
assessment service works is that they
take on 400 cases say in terms of the
first tranche but if they don't complete
For Occupational Therapy assessments
either because the person's declined or
they're they're not um they're refusing
just well declining either the service
itself or their needs have changed and
they don't want the service at all which
has happened in some cases they abandon
those cases and we replace them with
another set of cases you know just like
for like in terms of numbers so that
means that they're actually delivering
more than 800 that we've commissioned we
think that's going to be over a thousand
based on the number of cases that
they've abandoned so far with the first
400 so that will help us with the
waiting list so the current
OT waiting list is now 291 assessments
which is not where we want to be we're
doing a review of productivity within
the team to see if there's anything we
can do to support the team to be a bit
Slicker in terms of efficiency because
actually when you look at the numbers of
OTS and the number of Assessments we
should be able to be getting through
them but something's stopping them we
think the Elms when it comes in will
really help that process because at the
moment we have quite a paper-based
system and that's really tricky in terms
of managing and tracking where
everything is
um
so
that's a quick summary of that so the
next side looks at the stabilization
actions being delivered so we've talked
there about
um changing the process particularly for
delivery but also increasing the
capacity for drivers it's been really
difficult to recruit to drivers I think
this is probably a national problem
because if you think about it or the
Lorry drivers and everything it's just
been really really difficult to find
people who are do have the right kind of
license and are willing to do that we've
extended the opening hours and we've
encouraged self collections as well by
families and staff where those people
are connected to a service such as a
residential care home or for example
supportive living we're recycling the
equipment as well so that we maintain
those stock levels as well as purchasing
new ones
um and I think which is really exciting
we're using social care trusted
assessors to refer for simple items of
equipment and as part of the winter
resilience funding the discharge
funding we're also looking trialling
with um a home care provider
um the delivery of simple pieces of
equipment as well so we're rolling up
that trusted assessor model and the
great thing about that is if we can
scale people up to do the simple
assessments for simple pieces of
equipment that leaves the OTS to do the
more complex pieces of work so it's a
better use of their time as well so
that's really good and we've talked a
bit about the OT company
and we've got satellite stores so
everything isn't in one place we've
expanded the number of satellite stores
we have to make it easier for
professionals to pick up pieces of
equipment and deliver them when they go
and do their visits normally and and all
of those kinds of things so
um we have a plan in place in terms of
the One-Stop Resource Center so we've
got temporary equipment over 12 months
to support the service while the
stabilization plan is implemented so
that we continue to offer additional
hours to the existing team and any
agency stuff that we have we're really
looking forward to the album system
coming as you can tell and we're hoping
that it's going to deliver what we need
to deliver it should be in place in
September so when Richard comes back he
will be able to give you an update on
where we are with that
um and again we're going to review the
capacity in demand of the assessment
team
so the next part of the presentation
should I stop there and ask if there's
any questions on this bit
or would you like me to go on to the
adaptations team
uh seven sides but I can whisper with
them
if you like
yeah
at the end okay thank you so apologies
so the presentation actually refers to
activity in June 2023 rather than
November 22 we updated the presentation
but didn't update the date so please
don't think it's out of date so our
budget for this year for the disabled
facilities Grant is the grant the
council get every year
it is actually
um the the legislation that this falls
on under is actually housing legislation
so it's to enable people to be
independent within their house and it's
about looking at the interior of that
house and ensuring that it's fit for
purpose for that person to live as
independently as possible our budget for
this year is 2470
000. so it's 2.5 million roughly which
is quite substantial but we do get
through it very very quickly because
it's a demand LED service and if we run
out of money that's no reason not to
provide disabled facilities grant for
people
um disabled facilities grants can be as
expensive as the adaptation requires so
they can go up to some in excess of a
hundred thousand and there's nothing to
stop people coming back for more
um so they can somebody can have their
bathroom adapted one one application
then the next time they can come back
and have a kitchen adapted in this case
all that underpins all of this
um so it's a really interesting area so
we look at the applications for under a
thousand which
um are minor adaptations and generally
speaking they don't come out of the dfgs
dfgs fund anything over a thousand and
above
um we have panels once um every
Fortnight that we look at
um so we review all the cases that come
through and all the requests and we make
decisions on those we look at whether or
not that person is still having a
brilliant quality of life so what we
don't want to see is somebody whose
homes beautifully adapted internally but
they can't get out and they have no
connections with the community because
they live too far away to be able to
maintain those quick connections so
we're working closely with our
registered providers and our social work
teams and the OT teams to enable people
to think more broadly about an
adaptation and the circumstances in
which it it was is delivered the
presentation refers to the fast track
project which is the we piloted the fast
track first to make sure that we had the
process in place that worked
um and it got better outcomes for people
so as you can see it reduced um the
approval times to two to three weeks
rather than the number of months which
it could be because there could be a
two-week wait to get to the board to be
agreed and then a further wait for that
adaptation should be implemented
so we've restarted it now and it is
working really really well
so at the moment we've got four at a
team of five adaptations offices rather
than four adaptations officers we do
have a team of four normally we have
we've had to bring in an additional
adaptation adaptations officer because
unfortunately one person is off on long
term sick and will not be coming back
but whilst we wait that through work
that through with HR we want to make
sure that we have enough capacity within
the team so
um we have 148 State people as of this
presentation we don't have a current
waiting list we do have 36 cases in
process
so they're waiting the pre-approval so
before someone they work on the
adaptation actually starts we do a
financial assessment that Financial
assessment evidence is whether or not
that person for example is in receipt of
benefits and then we can just passport
them through and we know that we bear
the whole cost if they have savings then
we look at how much of their savings we
need to take into account in order to
deliver that adaptation if it's a
children's case it's free as well so
there's no payment for
um the family members to make
um
and sometimes people will drop out at
that stage if they're a homeowner will
put a 10 000 pounds
um kind of charge on the property so if
that person moves out when they sell the
property
um ten thousand pounds of the cost of
the adaptation comes back oops comes
back to the council
um
so
um the number of referrals that we're
getting are increasing and certainly
since the occupational therapy practice
has begun during the more complex cases
in terms of the fast tracks it's
increased quite significantly so that
throughput's really really taken off and
and that's good we're concerned about
you know running out of capacity so we
keep an eye on our capacity and we
monitor it we have to manage the case
size for the adaptations officer so that
they get a combination of fairly simple
adaptations and complex ones so although
an adaptation might have been started
say for example in March that piece of
work may take six to eight months to
complete that adaptation and the same
officer stays with it all the way
through so they hold that case and their
job is to troubleshoot and make sure
um and do all the snagging work at the
end as well and then if there's any
problems afterwards deal with those
problems as well so the next slide looks
at um the work hello today and Anna
who's the team leader has put down the
approximate cost beside it so the budget
although you can commit a budget say for
example in September of this year for an
adaptation we might not actually spend
that budget until next year next
financial year because there might be
work starting on a piece on an
adaptation and then we might have to
pause it during the winter period
because of poor weather so
um sometimes there's a difference
between what we think we might spend and
what we actually spend during the
financial year but again we track that
throughout the process and then the
final side just looks at the number of
referrals that they've got through
during that time
so thank you
thank you and thank you for the
presentation
um of the 800
um outstanding assessments that we've
given to a third party how old on
average were these are we taking the
oldest ones first or how long have these
people have to wait just an idea please
um so people we do have
um but we didn't monitor how long people
were waiting for to be honest when we
started this piece of work we knew that
the backlog was quite extensive but
because of all the paper referrals and
things it took a while to put things in
order and we now monitor how long people
are on the waiting list for and I think
the average is around 60 days it might
be I need to go back and check that just
to give you an accurate figure
um we did take we when we were ringing
people up we took the oldest first or
the ones that we were aware of being
oldest first but we also kind of um
scanned them and Screen them and made
sure that we also looked at the most
risky ones so we had to kind of do a
twin track in order to identify things
if there were very complex we'd keep
them with us if they were very simple
would send them over to the OT
assessment practice because what we
didn't want to do is let go of people
who were potentially very vulnerable
um with quality assured all of they have
their own quality assurance process in
place but we also quality assure the
referrals and the assessments that come
back to us
um and so far I think we've had an issue
with a couple
um but generally speaking they've been a
very high quality that I'm not that
familiar with NHS bandings but the OTS
who are carrying out the bandings of
band seven so they're they're quite
quality it's highly qualified and
specialists in their area
I do have a couple of questions but I'll
just start with one
um the 75 that have dropped off
is there any uh recourse notes extra
work of us to actually go back to them
after six months and after 12 months
just to make sure that they don't need
the adaptations or support because I
think one of the problems that we find
as counselors you'll find someone that's
come out of hospital I don't need
anything
eight months down the line they're
crawling around there downstairs not
able to get upstairs and no one's
actually followed up but there'll be
people that have refused help
and so I just wondered if there was any
work going on there to actually
monitor that group of people
there hasn't been to date and that's
because most the people that we've
handed over are people that have been on
the waiting list for some time so they
were going to deteriorate you know in
the way that you've described which we
we do see you're absolutely right
um we would have picked that up by then
so
my my next question uh with Elms coming
in is it going to be linked in with
mft's Hive system is there going to be
some communication there
um so because I know all the OT
referrals in hospital being done online
on hive
are we printing them out and then
regurgitating them into Elms or is there
going to be some communication with them
two systems
that's a very good question I'm afraid I
can't answer that can we get back to you
please thank you
can always ask a quick question you know
this uh the system that you're bringing
in the elm S2 now is that going to be a
more holistic one which captures a lot
the activity
um because I mean I know the
presentation didn't seem to have much
graphical information you know so in
terms of being able to extract data and
present it much more effectively and
also being able to link up with things
like you know what the the point that
was made about uh people not being in uh
and then that being captured in
priorities still being put on that and
not having somebody as a second person
uh on there you know as a standby in
terms of if you can't get hold of the
person that needs it and who's the other
person that's supposed to be looking
after that person or uh secondary
contact so lots of things to think about
as the as this software being used
anywhere else and is is it something
that you're taking a risk with because
we don't want it sort of falling down
yeah I mean I'll in terms of the detail
I'll I'll get some written feedback from
from Richard
um on the system but what I do know
about the system is it has been utilized
elsewhere as Karen has alluded to
um it is a significant Improvement on
the existing system which is very
rudimentary so part of the challenge
um Richard told me when pulling together
the report in November was just being
able to extract data
from the system it's very limited in its
reporting capacity this is the existing
system the kez system
um it also cannot group items together
so if somebody's got multiple items
they're all on separate lines which
makes the order really fragmented so if
you think about it there's a an analogy
of say an Amazon delivery where you've
got multiple items they're all grouped
together and you can see it in one space
in the existing system
it's really segregated
the the lack of kind of visibility of
the system also means that the kind of
customer service element isn't as good
as it can be as well because people are
not as responsive when when customers
contact them about the status of the
delivery because the system is is really
really poor so the the elm system has
much more functionality much more modern
system but I'll get rigid to provide
some specific detail um because it would
be really missing me to go into that I
don't have that level of detailed
knowledge I'm afraid yeah just just to
follow on it's being used in Manchester
at the moment so Manchester use it so
we'd have the same system across
Manchester and Trafford which would sit
well within mft obviously because also
you know the fact that when equipment is
out there and how quickly you can have
it returned or people finished using it
or for whatever circumstance that it's
turned round as rapidly as possible
so and just to come back on that point
absolutely one of the things that we've
not been good at historically is
tracking the equipment and getting it
returned in a timely way and obviously
some of this gets worth a lot of money
and can be recycled and reused but
clearly where there isn't an economic
driver to do that then we will dispose
of it but generally we'll try and
recycle equipment as the reports yeah
it's again the way that we manage the
system for I know because I had some
equipment from the One-Stop shop and I
had my hip replaced is that you get a
card that comes with your equipment and
that tells you what to do to return it
so I took the equipment back myself
because I could but not everybody will
be able to do that
and you see a lot of them don't you in
charity shops and On free cycle as well
which is such a shame
Council O'Brien I think you had a
question
I think you've probably already answered
this when you're answering councilor
Weston but I was I was going to ask
um what the average weight was for an OT
assessment
um I think did you say it was 60 days
or is that
I can give you the the current weight
before the end of the meeting if that's
okay yeah
um the other part of the question is
really how you prioritize people and
who's at the top and uh so probably it's
the same answer really took as you said
to Council western in in that we
prioritize people according to when they
come through but we also within that
have a grading in ABC grading system
that enables us to prioritize people
according to how kind of risky the
situation is at the moment okay so is
that just about is that just that taking
into account age and uh it would be
around vulnerability and Frailty and
it's a no tea makes that decision so
it's a professional assessment yeah
multiple factors taking it to account
yes yeah absolutely thank you okay
thanks
I'm sorry in Council accidents do you
want to go first job yeah
um yeah I've just um wanted to ask about
um I'm sorry I'm new to this so it's a
get out of my deck
um the the
um O2 waiting list due to lack of staff
and I just wonder about using OT
practice what what were the cost
implications of using that service
um and the other thing I was going to
ask was I understand the prioritization
it does concern me that people who may
not be such high priority
um it's not been looked at from a health
prevention angle because they're not
going to get what they need to stay at
their home in the home and be
independent because they're not
considered to be fast track if they have
to wait a long time so I was just
wondering about that as well thank you
sorry in in terms of the cost
implications for the OT practice
they cost 150 000 for 400 assessments
which is is relatively I think it's
pretty good value we wouldn't have gone
out to Tender for a service of this
nature if we could have recruited
OTs
that then would have been managed by the
OT team themselves but unfortunately
there's a complete lack of OTS and
that's why we've had difficulty
recruiting and vacancies and that's
contributed towards the current waiting
list
um I've just managed to get the report
up so the um
longest urgent weight
319 oh golly I wish I hadn't found this
um longer certain weight is 398 days
longest routine 403 days
so all right that was previously in the
longest urgent weight now is um 189 days
so
32 urgent routine 22. yeah it's not
brilliant is it that's not at all so
that's why we've had this um journey in
terms of
looking at how we might manage it better
I'm sorry could you give me the second
part of the question again
um it was just about the terms of
prioritization really and just whether
it was taken into account that although
someone might not be so frail
um in terms of looking it from a health
prevention angle it might be really
important to get them the equipment they
need much faster
yeah so in terms of the fast tracks that
that's determined by the nature of the
equipment rather than and the fact that
we can move it through the system quite
quickly and and get them in quite
quickly
um so they don't wait
um their wait a matter of weeks for
everything to be approved and then it's
just a question of getting access and
the design so things like stair list for
example you can get straight stair lifts
which are fairly easy and curved
stylists which aren't quite so easy to
fit and can take longer we don't at the
moment particularly look at prevention
um it would be something that we could
look at once we get on top of the
waiting list I think I think that's a
really good point to make we just tend
to respond to Urgent demand really if
I'm honest yeah it feels like you've got
no choice at the moment other than to be
objective yeah I understand thank you
and I was just going to ask sort of on
the back of those they are long wait
times aren't they have there been any
critical incidents or
um adverse
in you know critical incidents as a
result of people waiting for equipment
that
um they've needed and they've not been
able to access it in a timely manner we
don't know
this is the simple answer we're not
aware of any
um and certainly
um if someone had had a phone it's
because they were waiting for an
assessment we do tend to get complaints
um there are a couple of areas within
the council that have that receive the
most complaints and it tends to be
adaptations and waits for assessments
so
but we've not had any feedback to
suggest that might be the case
but okay maybe that sorry yeah do just
to respond
um I will ask Richard
um to check whether there have been any
serious or toward incidents reported in
the service and we can get back to you
on that yeah I think I think that's
important to know that isn't it because
it is quite critical isn't it that that
wait time really and you know that I
mean I know you've done a lot to sort of
mitigate that but um
um just another question with I mean
seems like you've had quite a good
service from the OT practice really do
you see that sort of being
maintained in the longer term or I mean
you said it was a waiting list
initiative is it finite or
um because obviously it sounds like the
the there's a massive Workforce issue
isn't there really and I know that is
universal in all Healthcare Health and
Social care isn't it's not exclusive to
this service but just how long do you
sort of predict because their services
will be used for at the moment there
it's planted you continue utilizing them
until they've completed the whole 800
assessments and we estimate that's
around September if we need to we can
review it at some point but we I think
to be honest in terms of that
continuative care and the relationships
that you have between people who require
adaptations and assessments and the
people who are delivering those it's
better to keep it in-house with that
staff team that are consistent if we can
but it's the most important thing is
making sure get people get services in a
timely manner
okay thank you councilor Gilbert
hi um I've got a few questions so I'll
do them one at a time if that's okay
um so the first one would probably link
to
um councilor Taylor's um which was about
forecasting so it seems like you've been
through like many services a kind of
period period of recalibration following
2020 and still working through that now
I just wondered kind of when you see the
light at the end of the tunnel in terms
of year-on-year services what do numbers
generally follow a particular pattern or
or other kind of circumstances where
there'll be kind of you know incidents
where it will Spike bad weather or
something like that so the hospital
discharges do Peak at key points within
the the calendar years you might expect
so
um we find they tend to peek around
things like bank holidays
um and also obviously around Christmas
but after Christmas rather than the
Christmas itself our busiest periods
tends to be around January February but
there aren't that many discharges over
the Christmas period but historically
though of course that's changing now
um so those will be key points of
pressure we haven't had a peak in terms
of referrals that are linked to anything
else a fairly consistent so we feel
we've got a grip on the demand as it is
we're not expecting it to change
everything seems to be slightly higher
at the moment because as you know during
covered people just manage to muddle
through so we will be getting a higher
peak of referrals now not just because
of the waiting list but because of those
people have been hanging on when we'll
get to the end of that we're not sure
really
um
thank you
um my second question was about
um communication with the people who
were on that waiting list so it sounds
like you're really hampered by the
systems I just wondered you know in
terms of
being productive kind of for you know
proactively managing the comms with um
those people on the waiting list great
to hear you mentioned customer service
Nathan love that so um you know what
will the new system give you and what
kind of what can you do piecemeal at the
moment just to reassure people really in
terms of thinking about Elms in its
capacity I've no idea getting what that
can do in terms of what we've been doing
up today is we've been ringing people
and we've also been writing to people to
tell them when they might get an
assessment
um and of course in answering the phone
although we do what we've been doing as
well as mystery shopping the the um the
eel line to make sure it's responsive
and actually it hasn't always passed the
test
um that we would expect it to so we're
working on improving that as well
so
I'm sorry did you want to yeah just to
follow up I I think it's a really valid
point and I wanted to draw it out in in
my introduction I think the the customer
service angle has kind of been lost a
little bit in the chase in the the
backlog and I think you know I mentioned
before this is tranche one of the um
progress improvements there are further
ones planned one of the key things for
me and Karen alluded to it I get
considerable amount of complaints about
this service it's one of the main areas
for complaints and a lot of that is
about poor communication so looking at
how staff communicate with that with our
customers thinking from a customer
perspective and being a bit more
proactive in in the comms is going to be
absolutely critical it's something that
I'll personally monitor
great thank you
um and last question uh was on the
um kind of the major adaptations you
spoke about um kind of means testing and
I just missed the beginning of it and I
wondered if you could share with me what
what's the kind of entry level or Park
area we're talking so that's so useful
yeah if people are on benefits then
they're just passported through if if
the um adaptations for a child it's
passported through if people have
savings then we look at the amount of
savings and take them into account so
people may be expected to contribute and
then the last bit was if someone's a
known or occupier we put a charge of 10
000 I mean if the adaptation is five
thousand then it's five thousand but if
it's eighty thousand then it's ten
thousand that's the maximum against
um against the property it's a charge so
that when it's sold we can recoup some
of the money back I think during the
time I've been working with the team
we've had one ten thousand back we also
work with the registered provide as well
so the housing associations and we also
ask them to return monies um
well to pay a contribution towards that
and that that varies in terms of success
across the piece and we very rarely get
huge amounts of money through that route
and then that's kind of moved back into
the council that's great so that kind of
10 000 number is really interesting is
there anything in terms of like salary
and income that's taken into account or
is it just that they're no an owner
occupier and not on benefits yeah it's
an owner occupier and it's it's it's
legislative kind of guidance that
enables us to do that but we can't go
above 10 000 no matter what the cost of
the adaptation is that seemed to be the
limit brilliant thank you
foreign
how many of those uh people are actually
waiting in a hospital bed for these
adaptations uh do we have that metric
because I mean we can say 300 days is a
long time and it is
um however if they are in a safe place
it reduces that risk to them as the
person
um but I know it's not ideal across the
board for someone to be waiting 300 days
for discharge
um that's one of my questions and
another one's come up probably
so as far as we know no one's waiting
for 389 days to be discharged because of
equipment this person will be within the
community that's so that person has been
handed over to the OT company so anybody
that would be the longest weight so
these are the outliers rather than the
average
um and then now the longest urgent
weights 189 days because we've done that
that scrutiny
um around people who've been set on the
waiting list
so uh would it be possible at some point
to just get the full Matrix of all of
those that are waiting and how many days
they've been waiting just so we're all
aware yeah so probably what we could do
is give you the the mean average and
then
um the median so the medians the the
kind of the average average weight and
the mean and then just give you the
outliers probably than the mean because
then if you get the mean it's always
skewed by those weights and sometimes it
can just be because we can't get into
that property or that person's not
answering their phone so it takes us a
while to get in there but eventually we
will do okay thank you very much the
next part was on the back of councilor
Gilbert
um when you've got I know you're working
with social housing providers is there a
housing swap mechanism to reduce costs
so someone's already had adaptations and
then they for one reason or another move
out of that house instead of adaptating
another house do you ask them to move
into that house that's already been
adaptive for them and on the back of
that how are you dealing with private
rented individuals private renters if
they need adaptations in the home are
you liaising are you finding it possible
to live aids with landlords effectively
so in terms of the already adapted
properties host hold a list of adaptive
properties so people are offered those
often people on the housing waiting list
want those properties rather than people
who are in existing accommodation we
find it very difficult to support people
to move they don't want to move it is
very difficult we offer a moving
assistance grant from the DFG in order
to support you know the costs of the
move just in case that's putting people
off we can't force people to move even
though we we might think that there's a
you know oh the Housing Association
might think there's a Better Property
down the road that would just meet you
on these veteran is easier to adapt
we're not allowed to do that either the
person has to agree to move there has
been case law I think it might have been
a new one where the council refused to
adapt the property unless the person
moved to a different property and they
were the council instructed to adapt the
existing property to for that family and
that was because they had local
community connections and support in
terms of caring for a disabled child
within within that family
um so oh golly that's where we've kind
of got to with it we do try so the idea
of having the OTS of social workers and
the adaptations officers visit is to
check that actually they do want to stay
there
um but it can be difficult for some
people especially if you're older and
you've lived there in that house for a
long long time you really don't want to
move
I'm sorry I forgot the second part of
your question okay
[Music]
that are now requiring adaptations are
you finding you're able to communicate
with landlords and are you getting a
response back that's acceptable
it's it's really interesting because we
haven't had a huge amount of demand from
people living in private rented
accommodation where we do
um we have to have the landlord's
permission before we can adapt the
property but we haven't come across
anywhere that's been anybody that's been
a barrier but I'll need to go back and
double check that I do know that in some
cases the registered providers have
refused the adaptation because they want
to maintain the homes as family homes
and sometimes the adaptation might not
lend itself to that so I kind of come
back with that one thank you
okay Council light
thank you
um well I am pleased to see that there
has been some progress in this because
it has been extremely worrying time
particularly when you have
um residents contacting you or even
organizations contacting you and so
um I recognize the progress that has
been made and obviously expect more more
to be there you said you've got a lot of
cases
um that are complex and you're expecting
that to rise is that because you know
already that these people are in
um
uh are ready to come out or how how do
you how you were able to uh quantify
that if you can
um it is in terms of the outcome of the
assessment really so what we do is we
look at the outcome assessment that will
enable us to kind of almost work out in
terms of the demand what the ratio is of
different people who might require
different adaptations I think in terms
of complexity I was thinking more of
people who if we had to have covert and
we've been able to support them at that
point maybe wouldn't have gained
additional Mobility or whatever issues
food so because people have just been
muddling through during covert they're
now more complex than they were at the
beginning of covert sorry I think that's
probably what I mean no that's
interesting because I was going to say I
presume we're not the only Council that
have had this problem because I know
taken away
um
OTS is
um does have a detrimental effect on on
that assessment and hopefully
um we can't you know there will be
um an increase
um everywhere because you do need
Otis to be able to to
um do that assessment is that all this
been fed back because I know the
pandemic was unusual and the fact that
it was so widespread but secondly we we
have if you like little lips but in
comparison for example flu epidemics or
we might have a some outbreak of
something else
and so is this all being fed back uh
nationally
um to the covert inquiry or at least to
the government because the other thing
is as well and there will be another
pandemic at some time early probably
sooner rather than later but the way
things
um are going unfortunately
um and it's just that preparedness
um because I think
if you look back things could have been
done a lot better
um and also a recognition that we do
actually need people on the ground to be
able to fulfill all the things that were
supposed to be fulfilling for our
residents
so we've we've kept all our files and
all the documented evidence that we have
we need to be approached by the covert
inquiry in order to feed that
information back up as far as I'm aware
we haven't been approached so far
um we're interestingly I was discussing
the the national directive to pull
people back into the hospitals with
Richard this morning we were saying that
if it happens again we would be saying
that you know we do need to maintain a
community presence in order to prevent
some of the deterioration that people
have experienced through no fault of
their own yeah
Council listed yeah it's just a quick
question really coming back to the
communications and customer service
element you said you get a lot of
complaints I'm just wondering
um how do you monitor
almost a customer satisfaction is that
done during the time they're making use
of the adaptations is there any feedback
requested
during the course of that time or at the
end of that time just to give a picture
really a snapshot of how the service is
working I mean I'm sure when you get
your new
um computer system it will be much
easier to gather data I like data
I like data too and to answer your
question from an adult social care
perspective we do very much that and
actually the the kind of um voice of our
customers and prospective customers is
really critical and we look for that
feedback loop I would have to double
check with Richard but as far as I'm
aware I don't think this is ingrained in
the service and it is something that we
need to replicate
working very closely with healthwatch
and age UK on the Improvement program so
that's a way of gaining an aspect of the
just ordinary residence voices and their
experiences and we are in terms of the
adaptations when the adaptations have
been completed the the organization that
carry out the adaptations are required
to
um have some kind of customer
satisfaction questionnaire with that in
for those customers so the at some
points there are but not necessarily all
through the system
I think this will be the last question
now because I think we've interrogated
you very uh intensively this evening
forgive me if I didn't listen or I
didn't hear properly is there a fast
track system for people with life
limiting conditions or people who are on
end of life type of Pathways yes yeah
yes there is and and obviously people
with motor neurone disease and the
neurological conditions because of the
the fast deterioration of that condition
sadly yeah okay all right thank you very
much thank you
we're the one on around the funding and
the disabled facilities Grant which is
the statutory thing isn't it this
funding provided by the government
yeah yes yes it is so it comes to us
through our better care fund and it's
part and parcel of that but we've always
had some disabled facilities Grant
um but for some time and it was we it
was set at particular level based on
submissions that we put in into the
department I can't remember what it was
called then but it's de-clogged now
isn't it so
um yeah so uh you've not got a situation
where you might be if there's any
equipment that's uh that you're awaiting
to get that requires funding or
something there's no you're not in that
situation
no so equipment and smaller pieces um
smaller adaptations are under a thousand
pounds come from a different budget it
comes from the council's own and funds
whereas the larger adaptations come
through the DFG the disabled facilities
Grant and in terms of procurement how
effective are you at getting the
equipment that you haven't got let's say
that you that you're needing additional
to what's being circulated or returned
and things like that are you getting
that at the best value
yes so we we have um contracts in place
for um some of the major adaptations and
the delivery and supply of equipment we
had problems during covid where we
weren't able to use our normal suppliers
and we had to use more expensive
suppliers we we generally procure that
across the system across the Manchester
and Trafford system and in terms of
identifying contractors as well we use
Manchester's framework in Trafford so
there's that consistency across the
piece as well in terms of delivering
those adaptations
yeah for that
yeah thank you chair I just wanted to
say to both Nathan and um Karen thank
you because and we know this isn't your
piece of work and you've you've you've
done really well to answer as many
questions as you have this evening so
thank you very much
yeah I think we appreciative of having
responded in the rehab because there
have been some wide range of questions
that have come out and they've been able
to uh respond in a very effective way so
appreciate that thank you so uh we'll
look forward to in fact the the next
update uh and hopefully you'll have the
uh I think it goes live in September
isn't it your system I know that's
correct chair and uh I think just to
reassure of taking notes of the the
questions for for follow-up and make
sure they're included in the notes thank
you very much indeed
so committee can we note the contents of
the report and the actions today
thank you very much
so item six discharged from hospital
support
and we've got I think Karen again for
that one
yeah I'm gonna lead off chair and then
hand over soon if that's okay
um so this is a report
um very much focused on on the work the
the council is doing to support
discharge but I think it's important to
know um as all the committee will be
aware it's a national priority
um and we take it very seriously in
Trafford with significant
um resources in terms of finances and
people
um attributed to this particular agenda
um because of our shared footprint
um with with Manchester with the
hospitals
um the main hospital sites being in
Manchester obviously traffic General
um a significant amount of our work in
this area is carried out jointly
um with with our colleagues across
Manchester City Council and through the
work of the local Care Organization
um so there are a number of uh programs
in place in this report
um covers the resilient discharge
program
um in a broad summary
um but I think it's important to note
that both uh our Council
um and Manchester have control rooms to
support discharge and we have a really
effective team based at Midway in sale
who who lead on that activity
um but running alongside it is a range
of interventions and I'm going to hand
over to Emma who's very much
um the expert in this field to go
through some of the things that we do
and but recognizing that you'll have all
read the report
thank you Nathan sure and I just thought
it might be useful if I just sat the
scene a little bit in terms of the
hospital discharge activity if that'll
be useful
um so we cover four main sites typically
um Salford Royal within Shore Manchester
Royal infirmary and also Trafford
General we do however support people at
the quest day um if there are residents
thank you
It's Not Butter
[Music]
come on
can you hear me now oh that's better
isn't it it's all right
um so we've got the four Hospital sites
in the main that we support
um we do operate what's called a trusted
assessor model from our site so of
colleagues who work in the inpatient
that seems they make the referrals into
our control room as Nathan described
um our control room is a really well
oiled machine I would describe it as
it's Health and Care we've got lots of
nurses lots of social workers lots of
strong leadership
um in the control room and they
facilitate people onto various Pathways
just thought it was helpful because I
know we're talking abbreviations all the
time so I'm just wanted to be really
clear where we're up to so there are
three Pathways there's pathway zero
which is where people go home from
hospital they don't need anything
support they don't need any support from
us there's a local Authority or from
health
pathway two is typically re-ablement
Pathways so therefore people who would
typically go into Ascot house for
example for somebody and pathway three
is how we often refer to discharge to
recess it's just always useful to set
those promises
um as you can see from the paper what we
do have is an improving lives everyday
program because that's what we're all
here to do
um and the key components of that is
about being efficient effective and as
modern as we can possibly be
um for our people
what we've done is gone through across
Health and Care we're committed to that
we've seen a massive focus on Hospital
discharge we want to change that
narrative really let's keep people
living well at home for as long as
possible with the support that they need
to prevent that hospital admission
um what we've then done is just pulled
together a number of schemes that we've
we're operating across Health and Care
in the community
um and I know we've hurt your chair in
terms of you've all read the papers so
I'm more than happy to pick up any
questions about any particular scheme
that we've got in there
thank you for that uh any questions
can we just take and go so long please
thanks it's not a question if it's just
too add really thanks Emma that the
health Team Works really really closely
with Emma and her team and I think
that's seen real benefits in the last
couple of years if things things are
really improving the throughput is just
miles more than it used to be when I
first got here three years ago and I'm
taking no credit for that that's Amber
and the team absolutely
um so we just wanted to make that point
really and we've also as you will know
we've pulled resources together in the
better care fund to really help that so
those decisions are joint decisions
around from the often you know as often
as we can so I just wanted to make that
point really that that's been a real
sort of shift in the last couple of
years thank you thank you for that gun
for report
I just want to Echo Gareth James I mean
no I remember working if I'm on service
and whenever I discharge back to
Trafford was mentioned a lot was groaned
so it has improved and I think that's
known across the board my
um question is about
preempting the discharge so do we have
any way of getting
um numbers each week from the hospitals
of how many Trafford residents have been
admitted either electively or emergently
so we can we've got that prep ready to
go and it's like these are people over
the next few days or few weeks that are
going to be filtered into our discharge
system is that already there because I
don't I'm reading it and I think it
might be embedded in this but I'm not
sure if I'm reading it right no it
absolutely is so we have four tracking
meetings a day for each of the hospital
sites so we can pick pick up the some of
the issues that Cameron was describing
people need equipment people who need
that local community support and we're
absolutely aware of everybody everyone's
length of stays tracked
um and we've absolutely got aggressed
with that and since that reason to
reside let's replace the old detox in
terms of yeah so we've got all of that
absolutely
foreign
thank you and again
um we just want to commend you on the on
the work that you've done to really turn
this around I'm just just preempting
preempting admission really
um and I know obviously people
particularly elderly people can't always
predict when they're going to go into
hospital but do you have any way of
um monitoring particularly frail elderly
maybe you're at home they have packages
of Care at home and and sort of just um
yeah just just this monitoring that you
know when they may be at risk of
admission really and and prevention of
that thank you no absolutely and as part
of the paper what we've included is
we've done a real heavy investment in
technology-enabled care for our
residents
um I've never heard anyone that's
aspired to enter into a care home I
don't know anyone here that would say oh
I can't wait to go into work at home
um so it's really important for us that
we're using technology to ensure that
we've got an Evidence base for decisions
that we're making but actually it keeps
PR people living in their own homes for
longer
um as well as that what we're looking at
is some restratification work so as
we're moving to our integrated
neighborhood teams really important
we've got that relationships with GPS
and we're going to look at those
specific issues to each neighborhood so
we can do that restaurant more but
absolutely Tech first in terms of adults
it also just tell us a little bit more
about how that works the tech I can yeah
yeah so there's a number of things in
terms of devices so any anything from an
Alexa in terms of that voice activated
work write Ultra robots which we've
purchased recently and their voice
activated models that we can use to
communicate so people can have video
calls with the families people are able
to contact the GPA the ambulance service
if they need that level of support we've
invested in some Digital support workers
as well so we've got that constant
dialogue but it also gives us a
dashboard is probably the best way to
describe it of the people
moving make sure that they're sticking
to the plant are they going out and
walking are they getting a drink are
they eating all those things that keep
us well and healthy so we'll have those
dashboards so the providers will have
that or the person's family members or
the professionals the social workers the
OTS those people working with them thank
you okay thank you
I just like to ask a question on the
virtual award I mean if you could just
elaborate on that uh
May cover some of the aspects you should
mention but uh
sorry did you say about the virtual
award yeah that was within the the
report wasn't it wasn't a mention of
that
I didn't mention the virtual award in my
report we were talking about how do we
get people home sooner and some of those
yeah I think it's probably
it is in the report yeah
do you want me to pick this one up okay
so um the virtual world
um has been a national uh policy which
is trying to bring Hospital Services
into people's homes there have been a
range of of different initiatives which
are broadly coalescing around that space
um so the mft group have christensen's
their offer hospital at home and it is
very much about how they can move a lot
of the the services which are very much
reliant on um technology and can be
self-monitored or with professionals
into the community it's very much in in
its infancy but it links into to what
Edmond was saying about neighborhood
working and that risk stratification
because ideally people do want to stay
in their own homes but it's making sure
that it's the right right person with
the right equipment and the right team
wrapped around them to do so safely so
it's not seen as a kind of second class
service it's seen as um really
maintaining people's Independence but
also
freeing up the the hospital beds for the
people who are really really critically
ill and need them
um there is certainly a lot of
information in that space um but our our
colleagues at mft would be best place to
to give a detailed presentation but I
can provide some written information to
the to the uh committee I think it's uh
it's almost like when people are
discharged it's a case of how they've
been looked after almost as if they were
still in the ward isn't it effectively
so it'll be interesting to add that I
think yes Emma if I may just come in
chair so I just like to draw people's
attention to 3.3 in the papers
um and the clients discharge from our
discharge to a SAS badge just before
we'll pick up any questions if that's
okay
um so this is really really important
for us so one when a person goes into a
discharge to assess placement which is a
24-hour placement uh statistics here
show us that 92.3 of our people go home
from that period of Rehabilitation on
recuperation very often it may be we're
doing a bit more work around that
um because there's there's kind of one
two under the Spectrum and there's so
we're either brilliant we're getting
everybody home or people's needs have
been over described probably a
combination of the of the two
um but I just thought that's quite a
powerful slide in terms of the amount of
our people that are going home thank you
chair
um yeah I just wanted to ask about item
17 the rapid assessment pilot because I
didn't really understand what it meant
when it says
um to meet people on their first day
does that mean the first day when
they're discharged or does that mean
there's really this intervention should
be happening before they're discharged
shouldn't it ideally yeah thank you
thank you
um so the rapid assessment pilot at the
moment we have social workers who do the
assessment so
um a person will enter a discharge to
assess bed we're committed to assessing
that person day one day five day seven
and we work through that methodical
approach
um what we did a small pilot so we
tested 10 people where you had not just
a social worker you had a you had a
nurse you also had a therapist that was
with you and when they all came together
we saw there was quite a sizable
reduction in terms of the amount so
whilst the figures are powerful in terms
of people going home and we saw that
people went home between 10 and 20 days
earlier so it's up to 28 days so we
think it's the right thing to do we know
that people when they've got that MDT
wrapped around them our residence
outcomes are better so it's something
that we want to continue with
foreign
I just want to move on to 0.9 and uh
Point 18 and I think there's another one
in there
um we know there's a struggle with
employing social workers and we know
that in our own Council we're actually
using a lot of agency staff to fill
are these going to be
are these roles going to be Trafford
only roles or are they going to be
worked across Manchester and Trafford is
there going to be joint funding for them
you know I just want it opened up a
little bit more and explain because I
think we're struggling at the moment how
do we expect to fill these roles if
we're already struggling to fill the
roles we've got
um and that's just no it's a really good
point um we've done lots of work in
adults in terms of reducing our spend on
agency in our Recruitment and we did
have we had about 20 Social Work
vacancies at one point we produced out
to about three and so we're doing
something quite radically different to
retain our social workers and these
posts at the moment are jointly funded
it's all right they're jointly funded
across Health and Care so we can do that
test of change really it's not recurrent
funding it's funding that we're putting
in to see if this works then we've got
that evidence base so I'm going to go
back to mft or go back to Salford Royal
or go back to whoever we needed to say
what this worked here's the data or if
it doesn't work at least we've tried
something I have to say it's a great
idea and I think it's long overdue yeah
and I think you'll get that from a lot
of nurses in accident emergency and in
rapid assessment areas as well
we need multi more multi-disciplinary
working to make it a lot smoother
through the
dare I say conveyor belt of healthcare
um so I'm all for this I think if it
works if you get it in place it will
actually help reduce the stay in
hospital and reduce the urgency for a
lot of people as well thank you
absolutely thank you Council Lloyd
I've got a number of questions
um when is the um online point one when
is that social worker going to be put in
place or are they already in place
sorry in relation to 0.9
.1 the with insurance the within Shore
social worker yeah are they in place are
they um they're in place now when we do
put in place uh Monday Monday okay God
and what about the uh the social worker
with nwas
social worker with them as we're working
through and how long do you expect for
that to take place and once it's
slightly more challenging in terms of
negotiations you've got systems that
need to work together and we've got all
of those we're having those
conversations at the moment there's a
commitment to doing it because we think
it's the right thing to do we know that
no I agree I agree I don't have any
problems yes it's early conversations at
the moment as we're working through some
of those gaps but it's being managers of
projects in its own right okay so you
would hope that it would be done
certainly by the end of the year perhaps
absolutely absolutely okay well it'd be
nice to have an update
um if we're having another update on
this
um the other thing is
um
the living rooms
and how many living rooms are active at
the moment and please can you do
something about the website I went on
the website I only looked at Monday oh
well I tried on Monday and then I went
upstairs and dried my hair because it
was taking so long and we have found
this
sorry but it's not the first time that I
found a problem with it and somebody
else found a problem with it because we
were trying to another organization we
wanted to go in when the living room was
active to
um be able to offer some Services which
would be in line with what you're doing
um and it's just too difficult to know
where and what so I want first of all
can the site website be improved and
secondly are they are they still active
at the moment
so absolutely in terms of the website I
will certainly take that back make sure
that when it's working it needs to be
needs to be up to date and accurate
information in terms of the
um the sites that we've got at the
moment so there's five official living
rooms that fall into this structure but
we do know that local churches and local
faith and Community groups set up their
own establishments in terms of living
rooms and what that looks like so I'll
take that away and I'll come back to you
if that's all right okay thank you and
how and how many non-resilient
discharges have you been have you have
you monitored those
you're trying to get resilient in what
made you do the resilience was it
because of the failed discharges
in in the main to be honest I think it
probably was and what was the failed
discharges figure approximately so the
resilient discharge program is a program
that's marked across mft but also across
our Health and Social Care Partners
um it was really important because we
saw the numbers increasing we've got
elected emissions that needs to come
through so it was something that we felt
that we needed to do and we broke that
down in terms of about to Basics program
so getting the basics right and making
sure that ours were
um we're working through our data is
giving us the rich information that we
need so it's a program led by mft but
we're all of Partners as part of that
resilient discharge program but you're
right it was it was driven by the fact
there was too many people staying in
hospital for longer than they ought to
be
going back to before
um at your point
um one of the problems is I think that
in hospital
and you go home I think it's at that
stage you need to be told that whatever
you've been offered it needs to be taken
up because quite a lot of people think
oh once I'm home I'm going to be all
right and that isn't the case
necessarily and I think that contributes
to fidelities charges
answers but you're probably right
um what would you do for anyone who's
referred into
um the control room so on to pathway one
so I they need some home care they need
somebody to support them we will always
offer them that stabilize and make safe
service first and foremost and we've got
lots of data on that haven't we in terms
of how many people stay with stabilizer
mates and and go on to further
Independence so happy to bring that for
that data to scrutiny if that'll be
required
apparently do you also want to respond
yes yes please sorry it's just in terms
of the um what happens to people who are
discharged so one of our ask off
indicators is the 91 days indicator and
what we do is we um look at the number
of people who've been discharged for
from hospital and still remain in their
own homes 91 days after discharge and
that we're doing really well on that I
think we're at 98 so we know that um
although we do have some issues around
discharge sometimes and the fact that we
might feel it's not the safest situation
for some people we do raise that
directly with the hospitals and we
troubleshoot those but um the way that
we're supporting people through that
journey is really really effective the
resilient discharge program I think is
is slightly it's more about getting
people out of the hospital in in a
resilient way so that process is really
robust then what happens to people when
they come out is more kind of the
council's social cares domain with with
some with support from Health obviously
if those people still have clinical
needs like for example District nursing
and things but we are working together
very effectively on that
I think Council of the party wants to
ask another question
hi mine is just her
a random question this so
how big is the stabilizer makeup save
make safe service team so how many in
Trafford how many members of Staff does
that team have that go out
so I'll pass that question over to Karen
in terms of the coverage today but we do
have an in-house modeling and an
external model as well
as ever describes we have an internal
model an external model we have 26
providers all of whom provide an element
of um stabilize and make safe service so
the way that it's operated is that when
someone needs that reablement approach
they approach we replace that person
with a provider depending on where the
capacity is and when that person
requires that support and how many
people they require to support them and
then after a period of assessment and
support it then moves on to discharge or
long-term care I can't tell you how many
people are in the the teams because
they're all commission services and
they're very good at flexing the
individuals in order to meet those we
could tell you how many hours we provide
would that help
yeah okay
council is later
the um
Yeah by all means yeah thanks very much
for that there's been a lot of questions
around this topic it's a lot of concern
so uh we look forward to the uh the
update as with that included thank you
one or two questions as well
I'd just like to apologies if it's my
fault with the website but it's the
second time I've been on it
okay thank you very much for that uh can
we note the contents and progress on
that
report thank you very much
and
item seven which is the integrated Data
Care partnership GM ICP update
yeah that's me thank you chair so so
quite a lengthy report for me because we
have met before for some time so six
items I won't go through them all uh in
some of this might be new for some of
the members so so happy to take any
questions if need be uh but I'll draw a
couple of the key points out if that's
okay and then
um ask Tom to come in just on one of the
and the sections and then we'll sort of
open that up for questions if we can so
just
had to start with the recap if we can so
on the first of July
2022 the ccg or the clinical commission
group that most people will have been
working with since 2012 I think they
came into being cease to be and the new
integrated care board were established
across the country so ours is the
greater Manchester integrated care board
or call nhsgm
um you know as abbreviation
those two things are the same thing so
so so
for the ICB each locality each Borah has
a locality team of the ICB so that's my
role in terms of all you know we work
with that locality team and work very
closely with Nathan and his team I mean
the council app the other partners and
so just in terms of that transition and
we talked about this probably here at
scrutiny
quite a bit and so so just to start to
draw that to a conclusion really so so
the consultation phase with the staff
and we're talking about 1 800 staff who
were transferring in from the 10 ccgs
into the ICB as we're calling it now
that consultation concluded so now we're
moving into the faith thankfully to
start to implement the new structures
where staff will get that certainty so I
have to say I say every time that the
last year and a half has been incredibly
difficult for that group of Staff but
hopefully we're getting to the point now
where people will get that Clarity and
what we think based on the impact
assessments we've done and we've done
many of these is the vast majority of
those staff will find a role in Greater
Manchester so most will get what they
want in terms of which locality but some
might have to move slightly but I think
in the main most of those staff and
that's really good because because it's
been a really concerning issue that I've
brought here on a number of occasions
just in terms of governance and
performance assurance and again we've
talked about this and I'm not going to
go through there are many of the detail
on the governments based on feedback
here at the committee just wanted to say
that we continue to work on that and
we've included some of the details in
the report uh so just to say our aim
with this is and it might look quite
clunky I guess in terms of what we're
developing is to try and make sure that
we do have something robust
to to enact and deliver it against the
accountabilities which are delegated
down to locality which are significant
but also not duplicate things for
partners or have meetings for meetings
sake so so this is a sort of snapshot
where we are now in terms of governance
that will change as we sort of refine
because we probably won't get it right
you know I'm in the first instance
just wanted to
to reference the work we're doing on the
workforce planning and it's come up a
couple of times both in terms of social
care and healthcare workers in terms of
the crisis we're facing now in terms of
that and that will only get worse if we
don't come together as a system to
address that so so Tom's been leading on
that on behalf of the locality team in
the council but
we've been working with all of the
partners
um across Trafford and bringing those
together in a workshop initially but to
to start to plot out how we will
collaborate to make that difference and
really have a shared Workforce plan
um and already seeing some benefit of
that and some of the work we've just
been talking about I mean in terms of
discharge so I just wanted to raise that
and then just the last thing I just
wanted to mention was nhf 75 so people
will be aware that it was his 75th
birthday of the NHS on the 5th of July
and that was even more
sort of important in Trafford because as
everyone knows the first NHS hospital
was Trafford General and so so that was
really great I think some really
um exciting sessions and events took
place hopefully most you were able to
access some of those so so we've
included some of the details of that I
think one thing to mention one of the
themes throughout that in terms of the
feedback and what we talked about those
sessions was trying to ensure our
communication on engagement with the
public is probably better than it has
been in the past so that that sort of
idea of making sure patients know where
to go to get the right treatments
whether that's the GP whether it is a e
whether it's 111 is really needs to
improve and there's a booklet which if
it hasn't been circulated have you got
them there have you uh Jane great so
that has been seen as a really helpful
sort of start in that process but that's
an ongoing sort of Journey with public
to make sure people do know where to go
because because that's probably been a
bit of a failure you know in recent
years people turning up any perhaps when
there is another offer in Trafford and
across the other boroughs so so they
were the things I was gonna draw out I'm
just going to ask Tom just to talk
briefly on the anchor institution work
because because it's really exciting
work we're doing in Trafford but also
across GM and then and if there are any
questions then then we'll come back to
that channel thanks thanks Gareth um
so as Gary said I think there's real
opportunity with the work that's been
driven through a report at the very back
end of last year about harnessing the
power in the NHS I think the lens that
we want to put on in traffic is
harnessing the power of traffic
integrated care partnership with all of
the partners coming together not just
the NHS but I think the NHS has um some
catching up to do with local authorities
in terms of how
um we maximize social value and that
that concept of being an anchor
institution in a community in a
neighborhood in a place
um so really positive that lots of
different people from lots of different
organizations have joined um what's been
referred to as the the NHS GM anchors
Network now and you'll see and it's
listed within the paper there's there's
three areas of focus following a number
of workshops around procurements with
such on procurement earlier on and
getting value for money and how that
value for money and that return on
investment can actually spin back out
into the local communities of Trafford
so ensuring that the Trafford pound is
getting its biggest bang for its book
but also the Workforce challenges and uh
culture and Leadership so those are the
three things that we're currently folks
in our efforts on within the network
um I think it's important to draw out
the excellent work that's happened
driven by the local Authority but much
more Landing in the NHS space now around
social value so the launch of the social
value Charter Charter the associated
action plan
um that we're contributing to and
driving forward with and the recent
hopefully recent interview hopefully
it's a very successful appointment of a
social value coordinator will really
start to give us an opportunity to
maximize the the impact of um the
Trafford pound both from a locality
delegated budget but also
um the uh what what's at the disposal of
the local Authority as well
um we've got good representation into
that through myself and through others
uh Oliver Schimmel um in the council as
well we work very closely together and
there's one other I think quite exciting
element and this is the bit that um
hopefully you'll be interested in is
they're holding ourselves to account but
so are we making the difference we want
to make
um and there is a live research project
with a number of NHS institutions and
and just very recently a couple of weeks
ago hence why it's not included in the
paper because it was on I think it was
the day the paper was submitted
we're having live conversations around
how we can create a set of metrics that
every NHS organization in Greater
Manchester signs up to so we understand
how they're maximizing their procurement
and their their spend and how that then
filters down through to localities and
how we align that with our corporate
priorities as a Borough
um which you know from a Health and Care
perspective will be our locality plan
aims and objectives
so we're having conversations and I have
a conversation tomorrow morning um with
mft about how we can maybe think about
how the NHS can capture those metrics
but how is a local Authority we can also
do the same and also having
conversations with the likes of Josh
Devlin in the volunteering Community
sector to see if we can capture how we
can do that as well so bringing it
together under that Banner of the
locality board and traffic integrated
care partnership I think is a an
interesting concept which we'll be
exploring over the next few uh next few
weeks so um exciting but early stages
with some of that work thanks
thank you for that report any questions
Council report
[Music]
thanks my questions
um
focused in on Workforce and employment
with the fact that
it's an hstn
um and there's a further scrutiny
question uh are we being scrutinized at
a GM level or just at a local Borough
level in each Borough
but back to Workforce are we able to
draw down money from the skills budget
of GM into our local schools and
colleges in order to start
apprenticeships in terms of care
apprenticeships and nursing
apprenticeships locally to start
building our Workforce
um I know that may be
you may need to go away and come back I
feel like
I could try and come in but the best
person who would have been able to was a
real good Insight is Emma who's
unfortunately just left us because I
know she's done some fantastic work
around the academy and and something
actually as a and Gareth order to the
meeting that we had of all the partners
coming together for the first time in
probably two and a half years
um one of the big opportunities in the
write-up from that was the ability to
enhance the current Academy model and
how we can think about that as a Whole
Health and Care system and that's why
we're being tasked and it's mentioned in
the report about the development of a
local delivery plan Workforce delivery
plan and that is about workforce
planning together and that sort of
understanding the risks and issues
around potential professions Etc so yeah
probably something that we could maybe
get Emma to bring some more information
back or I'll go and get it obviously
I'd bring it up just because I'm very
well aware the hospital hospital
settings had a huge issue with nursing
nursing level apprenticeships and how to
deliver them effectively and our
universities in the main especially in
Greater Manchester were struggling to
integrate uh friendship level no you
know nursing level apprenticeships into
their academic gift into their uh
prospectus because they it was just a
struggle one of funding but two of
placement because you get a job and you
work at that job and then you you earn
while you learn and and it didn't Link
in with nmc guidelines and so I know
those Publications there thank you
yeah just just to come in on the point
about
um you know employment working skills I
think it's important to know the the GM
Devolution deal
um has a focus on Health and Social care
recruitment so there are going to be
devolved monies coming coming through
that route in the future
um as Tom's alluded to I'm happy to
provide a little bit of an update on
foreign
I'm not an expert on Devolution so I'd
have to get back to you on that but in
terms of the um
the approach
um around working with schools and all
the other facets of um work we're doing
to to try and attract young people and
and people who've perhaps fancy a change
of profession into social care happy to
do a little bit of a written update on
that for you
um yeah um
taking this long to get the workforce
sorted out is this having any impact on
delivery plans
um well we've spoken before here haven't
we that we have struggled with delivery
and Recovery I think but that perhaps I
don't think that results from the
transition people have just got on with
doing what they were doing so I think
and I've talked to you before I think
there's probably a risk of duplication
that there's been over the last six
months 12 months where people are
probably doing things because we've
always done them in the locality and
maybe someone else might be doing them
so I don't think that's contributed
to the performance and delivery issues
that we know we're facing and there's a
huge challenge both financially and in
terms of performance um isn't it but I
don't think it's contributed to that
although I suppose
people are exhausted by this whole
change and you know I would be very
surprised in some cases if sickness
levels haven't been affected by it so so
I'm sure you know your question is
probably really good and it probably has
had some kind of impact but nothing that
we've been able to measure but it has
it's been an awful time for staff and
what do you think of the biggest risks
um to the ICB in Trafford at the moment
well you know the risks are numerous I
mean I talk about the finance risks and
we've talked well I'll tell you what it
just picked three the the top three and
then I'll come back when you come back
again it says I'll say finance and
performance in its General sense and
I'll name a couple of them so so the
financial plight of the ICB now is
significant so so we have submitted a
balanced financial budget for for this
financial year but there's a huge
efficiency requirement to meet that so
that's it with providers with the ICB
itself and the locality teams in
everything we do so in all of our
delegated budgets we are really having
to make sure we get as much out of that
money as we can you know without
affecting Services clearly so so
Financial sort of leads to everything
really but in terms of performance
we're struggling across the board
against a lot of the key metrics that
people will be familiar with thanks for
the Constitutional targets although in
recent months you know there have been
some real improvements around the number
of people who are waiting for elective
for example the counter targets have
been a real struggle but I think we're
starting to see some improvements but if
we're not seeing that Improvement in the
summer I think I think we you know we'd
be really worried wouldn't we so so I
think performance across the board and
you know something we're taking very
seriously the bit that we're still
working through exactly what performance
measurement that we'll have in locality
and what we'll be doing coming back to
your point is what will be done once at
the GM level so so we've got a fair idea
how that will work now but I think
they're the two challenges I'd say but
within performance it's really
multifaceted and there's lots of things
and we can bring back detailed
performance as we said in the past if we
need to in terms of some of those key
areas
and it would give us a good idea because
you're saying well
um the money
um which is fair enough because actually
money is always a problem within the NH
in in the NHS anyway but also to see
what what what the pressures are because
we don't I presume I can read the papers
somewhere but it'd be just interesting
to have those
um in in just to be able to read it it I
feel that there should be a bit more
here for me because I I don't have a
full understanding of the actual ICB
particularly that I'm interested in but
the effects on greater Manchester as
well and I think it's important uh for
us scrutiny councilors that we do have
that picture because otherwise we can't
scrutinize you
yeah I mean I totally agree I think I
think that's great and we've offered
that in the passage it's quite hard to
know what level to land that at because
we could have a huge document and give
me anything you like okay go perhaps
through the chair if we agree on the
work plan and we can bring some
performance data back to a future
meeting if that's that would be useful
it looks like it's something that the
members
yeah you know perhaps if we aim to do
that in September and really concentrate
on the areas where we're most concerned
maybe if we start with that yeah
really
are you
mentally uh odd question
with your financial challenge
did you acquaint for having to fund any
staff pay increases because I know the
government isn't backfilling uh money
this financial year when they're handing
out their pay increases they're making
schools and hospitals actually to pay
for themselves
so out of the current budget you have so
is that going to be another chunk that's
taken out of the budget in order to
fulfill the pay increases
for that question so so I'm aware of the
recent announcements that you over some
of the money then there will be some
further funding for the providers for
the hospitals
for the commissioning organization of
the ICB and our locality teams we
are attempting to fund the increases you
know the inflationary rises from within
our existing budgets and that's one of
the reasons why we have I know I I pull
that face too so when we look at the the
forecast for the year that's one of the
pressures which we're trying to to
balance within that the settlement is a
settlement for 23 24 I understand uh and
it's you know that's one of many
Financial challenges
important did you mean the um
apprenticeship
because we use the apprenticeship Levy
in the council for bringing it for
social care don't mean I was just
wondering if you meant if you meant that
because yeah you do you do bring in
apprentices don't you um on that yeah
it's across the board I know
um in Trust
so mft is a an education provider status
so they draw down in order to deliver
their level twos and level threes
um as well as the pharmacy level four I
think they've expanded into now
um but they cannot provide the nursing
apprenticeship which is the level five
level six that has to be done by the
universities and the universities are
just struggling with that it's a
disconnect and and it's a flaw in in the
makeup of the system
within that office when we were working
together it was we noted that as a flaw
of the design of that apprenticeship it
was a case of
you have the nmc guidance and training
guidance for student nurses
and then the government has created this
nursing apprenticeship
that doesn't match the nmc guidance and
so universities aren't they can't put
the two blocks together and I think that
is still a struggle and it's something
because the pandemic they haven't gone
back to and DFE and
dohsc now haven't gone back to together
to actually work through and I know the
nmc has just sat there with their report
going well this is our what we're saying
someone answers and no one has
foreign
yeah I'm just going to say I'd be really
interested in in looking at the the ga
manca Institute again out on scrutiny I
think they're really it sounds like it's
a really exciting project I just want to
say and what we've been talking about
apprenticeships I actually met NO2
Apprentice when I was a holiday last
week so I didn't realize you could be an
OT Apprentice so that's really exciting
I think yeah thank you
uh just a question from me around that
locality performance framework thing is
this uh initially or mainly going to be
based around a standard model of some
kind that might evolve or is it
something that's going to be more
nuanced towards the various districts
you know the Trap would have in its own
specific
evolution
so it's a great question and if we both
and also so so we will get the SE
standard Suite of reports coming out of
the central team but also have local
Resource as well and so it's a business
intelligence
provision so so we'll get standard these
are the metrics
are particularly
interested to to the traffic locality in
this apartment so so we will be both and
we will have access to
because even
if it's not formally delegated it's
still really interesting because
the population health impact
those things
so I saw folks really to try and get
that balance
just to expand only very very slightly
and just to say that we've got um really
helpful conversations happening with
Helen Collins as the Director of Public
Health
to look at not just the facts and
figures of how many people have less
hospital and those types of things which
are obviously extremely important but
actually understanding some of the more
preventative measurement from a
population Health perspective so it
won't just be a very health driven um
scorecard or dashboard or whatever
language we want to use but actually
it's about bringing the world of health
and well-being board and prevention
alongside the more sort of um planned
and reactive Health and Care measures so
it will be seen as a as a reflection of
our locality plan across health and
Health and Social care
[Music]
thank you very much can I just backtrack
slightly to sort of where we started
really about the the governance the
Trafford locality governance and and the
model that you've got on page 37 is that
how it is now is that the final model
because it says this is the current
governance I mean I know you said you
know you're hoping to keep it pretty
much is that as it's going to be for the
foreseeable future do you think now
so this is a governance we've agreed
through the locality board so this is
what we are implementing so most of this
has actually been operating so for
example you know provide a collaboration
you know where all providers come
together in Trafford uh the locality
board have been operating for some time
now and are really finding their feet
some of the other groups are relatively
new so probably will change so
um as I said in my introduction
is if we find that if there is
duplication then we will make some
changes to this and it's one of the key
sort of outputs from the GM
um carnal photo work is described out
you know but that was a sort of
diagnostic of the governance the
leadership so it's a wrote clear clear
recommendation was not to have too many
meetings not to be over governance so I
know this looks quite a lot so so we
will sort of run with this but then
Implement changes if indeed we need to
you know in collaboration with the
partners thank you is it possible and
this is maybe just been very struggling
to grasp all of this is it possible to
maybe have just a simple and a council
I'd maybe could access information it's
a bit more sophisticated a very simple
overview of what each of these organ
components of this governance model do
how they interact and maybe what the
impact is on you know the receivers of
these Services really yeah the
recipients I should say is and maybe
that's a really naive and stupid
question I don't know but
um I'm sort of thinking of it you know
how I would maybe explain it to my
residents and I think I need to
understand it myself before I can take
it out elsewhere really
sorry to us the very stupid question it
really is is not um it's an absolute
sensible question and it's one that all
our partners so even the people within
the system here this is really new to
people
um so and that sort of critique
particularly um different levels of
organizations who don't necessarily
expose to some of the documents that
maybe people hire up are exposed to
understanding how you navigate a Health
and Care system to get decisions made or
raise issues
um it's fundamentally important isn't it
um to aidazole in our continuous
Improvement Journeys
um
just yesterday I delivered a
presentation and I tried to be as simple
as possible to the public health Team to
say this is our sort of new system as it
started to evolve and put up this
diagram and there's an existing slide
deck I pulled together which has and
I've tried to do it as simple as
possible it's got two sentences on the
key purpose of every one of those green
boxes
the health and well-being blood so
hopefully that might be a helpful
starting point and it actually includes
and I was I wasn't necessarily going to
jump into mention this but although
there's a reference to health and
well-being but there's lots of
um uh very focused and thematic
multi-partnership groups that sit
underneath them driving the prevention
agenda and the health and wellbeing
board strategy
um the presentation that I've just
referred to includes um information on
for example the tobacco Alliance the
substance misuse group that we have Etc
so and that's all in the same document
so I could just finesse that a little
bit and happy to share that with
everyone
coming up I just wanted to say if we
want to have that prevention people have
got to understand what you know what
they're looking at and where to go so I
think that joint forward plan that's
come out of the I um gmicb is going to
have an easy read version I think that
what we tend to do is we tend to write
for a white middle class children of
about age 15 but really we need to be
writing four between five and
nine-year-olds so that everybody in our
community is able to engage and that's
why I think this document this little
booklet that we've made sure that we all
we got one for everybody it's really
helpful because we did we did some
testing with this at the 75 and 75th
birthday party for the NHS and we had a
group of children and we had a group of
older people and and the children knew
the answers without having to look at
the book actually they were absolutely
brilliant and you know some of the older
people were saying oh if I caught myself
I'd be off to a accident an emergency
but the kids were saying no I just get a
plaster or I'd just do this or you know
and if we don't get it right we aren't
going to prevent and we are going to be
having a costly
um Hospital aren't we Hospital provider
so and I think that what you're saying
around
um
having easy read versions it's just it's
essential I need the easy read versions
if it's if it's longer than a couple of
paragraphs I'm done so I think that I
think that easy read version for all of
us thank you
yes absolutely it is a really useful and
simple booklet helpful to anybody really
and the more places that it's it's
available I think that'd be better
actually yeah
good
so is it okay for us to leave now that
you're going to do your um
you're prepared to work for the rest of
the year
I'd love to stay well
some work to do before the morning
oh thank you thank you
keeping you away
all right okay
so uh Health screen
our security committee work program 23
24. uh committee I considered items on
the committee's work program so uh
can we look at that then
has anybody put anything down on there
for uh
discussion
wasn't actually yeah these are sort of
established and kind of yeah
so these items on here are these
definitive oh is this what we're doing
yes yeah has everybody sort of agreed
with those are they happy with those
because they do seem to follow on from
not as done before and it's just
updating and consolidating on someone
Council western sorry um
a simple question I've got a further
data on my calendar of the 15th of
November for health scrutiny meeting and
it doesn't seem to be on these sheets
I know we normally have five meetings a
year don't we
three
control oh yeah I think there is yeah
right there
it's definitely not only on the calendar
yeah
oh God that's on
meetings within a municipally here
normally don't we
right so it will be amended yeah
I'm just thinking because the September
meeting looks like there's an awful lot
on there
um
yeah
perhaps it's just a suggestion um
hi hi thanks yeah just um having read
them for a second time just now
um I wondered if we had room and maybe
with what Denise has just said there
might be room
um for an update on access to GP care
just feels a little while since we had
one and the ones that we did have was
really excellent and I think it's
probably the right time now to have one
as we're gearing up to Winter
we did have a I think the consultation
didn't quite pick up what uh the GPS had
response there wasn't much of a response
was there from the GP surgeries
no we didn't I've done it previously as
a task and finished group actually yeah
we did it last year as a task
we did that report should be published
and go to
um the executive shortly I thought I
said come to Hell's scrutiny yet though
I don't think
level of access to GPS
the available update was provided by the
chair who along with other members
present today formed the health test the
finished groups
okay sorry if I made the report at the
moment is with CLT
so and after that we'll come back to
scrutiny and then perhaps we can just
decide what we do next with it
well um I mean I was thinking about that
report but I'm afraid I forget the name
of um a couple of
um doctors that we had a couple of years
ago that came to update us
um do you remember Judith yeah and
everything in the garden was Rosy wasn't
it
[Laughter]
found that quite useful
um I just wondered if it was time to
bring back people in from that
perspective again but are absolutely
open to everyone else's opinion on that
especially in light of the task and
finish group
the only thing that I've lost on we've
done a report haven't we task and finish
group it's supposed to go to the
executive ASAP after it's been written
so there was a variable update
um the report wasn't completed it was in
draft form and so there was a verbal
update from the previous chat to
executive and Council
and then now it's sitting with the CLT
for final approval before it comes back
to you guys
sorry is that the reason why it's uh not
being mentioned on this one though
yeah right okay so we we need to uh
wait for that report from the CLT to
have discussed it and see what they've
said
when can we expect that report back
possibly within the next month
so
so do we need to add it to an agenda
then to
we can put that within the November
meeting okay because I was going to say
this the agenda for September is really
heavy isn't it yes not too many items on
it so I would have I've thrown some of
those over I think really wouldn't we
yeah so that this gives the opportunity
then to be able to
start to you know also give them the CLT
time to respond
the update that we had from the GPS
wasn't that under the ccg
or was it from the ICB
because I think one of them Mark isn't
it he's
um he was a GP rep of some kind
well I think it was when it was still in
the ccg I think the report or the last
update we've had from GPS I can't
remember exactly predates the cicb has
been going a year now isn't it I think
and he was the
sort of primary care leader I can't
remember his exact title at Trafford ccg
just if it helped Jeremy the ICB is
still responsible for commissioning
primary care so
um certainly we could we can make
inquiries
um and get some money to come to the
garage so we can get to him to or her to
come to the meeting and you know report
on it
okay
would that help
members
yeah yes okay thank you
counseling Oxford
foreign
[Music]
um
I think with an overlap with some of the
other committees it's a shame that
Council Slater's gone now but I think
happens is that some people just sort of
think my parents
[Music]
and health food and go to somewhere else
as well
they'll probably come from the ICB
wouldn't it suggest that rather than
coming from this committee should really
be the the overarching committee
shouldn't it
and look at that sitting
well could we could we have a look at
Social prescribing you know what is
available what an Italian with like
about GP Services as well winter and
health prevention I thought that would
be a piece of work that we could look at
okay maybe it's a task can finish you
know what what is the provision of
social prescribing within this Borough
and what is the impact of it and is it
you know is is there Equity of access
throughout the borough you know what
what services
well yeah
I think it's it's going that way now
isn't it to a certain extent I mean
there's been a certain reluctance from
pharmacists to prescribe or uh discuss
conditions with people that come in
obviously because they don't want to be
committing themselves to saying
something that that they're not in a
position to say even though they know
football well what to say
who you are found I mean I had my own
idea and I know the email Trails we all
had our own ideas so it's awesome
finished
um
see that because it's it's trying to
bring it fairly close uh we could focus
more locally couldn't we on the Trafford
side
I wanted to know a secure units are up
to scratch in case traffic is being
placed in I I know
because there was no bed available so
what are they doing for part their
discharge protesters and they liaise it
with our team here to actually get them
into a local
maybe
it depends on the numbers doesn't it uh
if there's only I mean I don't know what
the situation is but it's just very low
numbers it may not necessarily
I I think the problem
I mean there is there is a problem you
know in terms of being able to get it
yeah it's not easy because they say well
you have to go 999 on it
anyway
so we've accepted we agree with the
item nine can we approve that then task
and finish group yeah subject thank you
very much indeed and item 10 any urgent
business
nope and exclusions resolutions no
motions
item 11. so
close the meeting thank you very much
for your attendance